what's up y'all i'm back with the black
widow herself scarlett johansson give it
up
uh black widows are badass but they're
also a little creepy
so in honor of scarlett's new marvel
movie um it's time to play what's
creeping up on me
[Music]
[Laughter]
i love that one oh jessie it was awesome
how competitive
are you scarlett um i'm pretty
competitive especially when it comes to
gaming yes there is no other answer
for me on that question um so well we're
on the same team um in this game which
is good because
you know now scarlet's having technical
difficulties which happens almost
every other show in the world of now
covent tv
so we're going to just have to improvise
this game
like they do on snl so here's what will
happen
i will have a green screen behind me i
can't see what's in my screen
so scarlett will give me clues about
what's creeping up on me
without saying the name of the thing i
can pass if if one is too hard
and if we can correctly guess ten things
in
one two minute round the audience will
win a cool prize now i have no
doubt enough i have no zero doubt we are
are you ready
okay okay god i'm sweating i have like
flop sweat
oh my god it's gonna be good it's gonna
be good a little sweats good little
nerves are good okay
okay go
is that oh no um it looks like a
big there's ah
it flies it looks like a flying lizard
dragon
dragon
[Applause]
mark ruffalo plays this guy he has an
anger management problem
yep um wow this is scary
um it's hairy and it's got big things
and it stands on two feet
werewolf yeah yes
oh it's flying um and it likes fruit and
vampires turn into it and um it
gets wait okay
it is still flying above you oh what the
heck is that a kid oh
that's cute okay it's um there's 101 of
them and
yeah right is that what it is
oh it's um like it kind of you can do
this
um this oh uh yummy i like this um it
has brooklyn
uh whoa these come from outer space
they have big eyes yeah
oh gosh that's it's got to eat legs
spiders falling
no spiders it is
[Applause]
i was like i literally was thinking like
i grew up around tarantulas in texas i
don't know why i said it at first
um we did it i mean you're i i
hope you see the footage of you when you
see things your expression when you see
the pictures
it's amazing um you have stories for
each one it was awesome
okay um so we're amazing audience and
that means that every one of y'all
is a winner as well so the hypervolt doe
is an affordable ultra lightweight
portable massager made with simplicity
in mind
it's made by hyper ice and industry
leader in recovery technology
and everyone in the athletes is getting
one
thank you for playing scarlet we were
awesome
yeah i think we were awesome and also
those um those
massage gun things those are those are
no joke you could do some serious damage
with
i know i love them all right everybody
black widow is out in theaters and on
disney plus with premier access this
friday
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help